[ __ ] Tyler's completion call me
back but I'm gonna have them drop me in
America this is real bad
yo any updates cuz I'm like really
struggling to hang out here and I'm in
really bad shape here bro
I mean not only am I gonna be late I'm
gonna miss the whole draft we need to be
way more like yeah are we are we are we
calling did we call every private like
that we fold okay so can we
okay let's let's look to a circle let's
do one circle you got your perspective
I want to be happy don't you want to be
happy these sports cards I thought
you're retired I don't think most people
know that there's a there's gonna be
several 10 20 $30,000
Xion cards to be had out of four or five
dollar packs that's like a lottery
ticket
that's better than a lottery ticket
because there's other cards do not tell
him I'm not full around like I'm looking
at me like I think anything if you
actually bought a certain couple things
I think it's like one of the scariest
guaranteed fifty to hundred percent of
ticket value in twenty four months
completely like what up a things I've
seen in a very long time
but you gotta move on that way it's
happening right now yeah it's happening
right now you know it's so I'm watching
it's unbelievably you know like if you
if you don't have like say you have
under write you don't lie under it yeah
it's under under you know this is like
my whole [ __ ] mantra of like garage
saling and everything like for example
if this conversation was happening in
October I don't be like kill please by
two giannis rookies in here 170 bucks
they're gonna go up there [ __ ] 450
now so you take that now you got a
thousand now you're sitting here today
and I'm like okay thousand what would be
like
um make the second a thousand lien Luka
Don I'd pop by Lucas for 50 apiece buy
20 of them and sell em for 75 apiece in
October when the season starts just it's
just guaranteed you might want to take a
risk on darn old bakers a hundred bucks
bass rookie Darnell's 14
and like that just doesn't make any
sense to me
and so if Donald beats Baker on Monday
Night Football and week two I just think
like the math can get the ad real fast
and then if you have more money the real
thing to do is buy these basketball
cards that are about to come out and try
to pull it's gambling you pull up
[ __ ] $5,000 Xion rookie card cuz it's
all one of one one of 50 patches autos
to call them it's it's really happening
though like all these sneaker kids are
getting into it my generation is having
has children now of the age that can
collect that's what happened to me and a
lot of other people see you say that all
in all the stuff that we collect in
Batman
or it just doesn't doesn't have a value
what's up lock the cards that we used in
life no value no value
you gotta get him greeted and there's
like not a lot of carts worth clean I
mean let me rephrase were you smart
enough to buy 8687 FLIR basketball yeah
that's it you know that was one that was
the thing to buy eighty-seven tops every
single kid you know right this has
always been one of the most classic
rides into a city this Chicago right
[Music]
[Music]
about to go give a speech in Chicago
okay it's a United Center how it does be
to him
I'm gonna be hyped 9,000 people in the
United States my opening line might be
[ __ ] Michael Jordan because I hate
Michael Jordan I [ __ ] hate Michael
Jordan I hate Michael Jordan literally
literally somebody this is not just
crazy literally somebody just texted me
just don't look up at the six
championship banners and you'll be good
go have fun
today in Chicago I'm definitely starting
with [ __ ] Michael Jordan now don't lose
40% of the crab before we start this
happened we won't be able to share this
but um but we will in the future for the
vlog actually just this happened because
this kid is the vet this is the kid we
drafted he sneezes blesses himself and
thanks himself
[Music]
listen to them I kind of like you know
of me guys I'm so fired up to me with
Andrew Wardle on the money is podcasts
to have an authentic conversation April
29th Hulk Hogan that's literally what I
did I know that I it's really crazy to
me that when I do promo content videos
I'm literally just reenacting 1987
wrestling huh
if you think the Undertaker's got a
chance you've got another thing coming
in I eat berries like it's my job mr.
per 30 I ate look at this there used to
be blueberries here like it's my job
notice you just like devour cuz I'm
trying to accomplish [ __ ] out here
people use [ __ ] lunch and dinner as
an excuse not to do I'm on to you [ __ ]
basis whatever is a great clip Africa
that's like a great standalone clip
it's crazy
hey good see how you've been good good
good did you want a hit sitter just what
hats that would be great are you all
right let's get you out no problem
I feel feel very confident I have been
focused you see it thank you for the tip
I mean following your lead it was great
4:30 wake-up call Wow yeah we got a
beanie today for the first time ever
so like struggled like sleeping cuz I
need the beanie to cover my eyes yeah
that's how I sleep I the reason I wear a
beanie is because I on the flight I
cover my eyes that's why I wear it in
the summer too uh-huh that's the fun
fact of the day we're on the same page
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
when I'm Chicago
the single biggest thing in my opinion
that the majority of these people in
this room are doing wrong this is number
one I believe that 98% of the people in
this arena right now by too much dumb
[ __ ] I have become crazy fascinated as
I've lived my life of trying to
understand why the [ __ ] so many of my
parents immigrants friends other
immigrants and just immigrants in
general have a disproportionate success
rate in the framework of America and I
finally figured it out it they're not
smarter that they work harder it's that
they come to America and they buy
nothing stupid for 15 [ __ ] years they
just live like [ __ ] buy nothing save
money buy a business and move on the
level of insecurity that isn't
permeating this country so that people
end up buying cars and houses and
clothes that they can't afford to
impress people that they don't even like
is the great epidemic in our society
I get to say this from truth I lived my
20s all my twenties 22:29 my twenties in
a shitty [ __ ] apartment in
Springfield New Jersey I didn't buy any
[ __ ] clothes I didn't have swag
[ __ ] sneakers I think I went on no
[ __ ] vacations
I just [ __ ] worked and saved money
and I was building a business for my
parents not even for myself so when I
tell people to be patient it's easy
because I lived it I don't stand up here
ever talking about [ __ ] that I actually
do first and so if you're not pumped if
you're not like loving life before you
try to figure out the hook or the secret
or if you think Tony's gonna rejigger
your [ __ ] brain or I'm gonna give you
or I'm gonna give you some [ __ ] secret
to do on [ __ ] Instagram that's gonna
change everything before do you think
about that go home and look at your
[ __ ] credit card bill and stop buying
dumb [ __ ] [ __ ] talk about this that's
the game that's the game please wake up
I love you Chicago
[Applause]
I see you back there I see you up there
[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]
hey guys I just took the stage in
Chicago swipe up to see what I just did
hey guys just gave a great talk in
Chicago at the United Center a lot of
mine sets up some new stuff a lot of
your stuff came out Kaleb I'm super
excited about it hope you enjoy it leave
a comment below on what new stuff really
caught your attention especially if
you're a hardcore consumer of my content
right now like the best kept secret like
I just partnered up with Rob you'll
appreciate this I was the best kept
secret for 11 years like think about
this dude you were shot in the [ __ ]
head you're so lucky to even have this
at-bat
it's what I set up there I know you're
hungry right yeah and you want to be not
the best-kept secret you want to be on
but I'm telling you right now the best
era is when you're the you know
best-kept secret
enjoy the [ __ ] out of this process I
loved a little bit deep down being
underestimated you know just enjoy our
do cuz in five seven nine years you're
gonna be known and then it's gonna be a
different thing enjoy this process your
youngest [ __ ] Gary we have hello I love
the pic I don't know if you saw this but
I just tweeted it the kid we picked
Quintin Williams was doing interview
yesterday he sneezes during the
interview he says god bless you to
himself and then thanks himself for
saying god bless you that's when I knew
we picked the right guy
mine's delayed but I asked them to like
find a different one yeah did they not
hit you up did they not hit you up for
logistics maybe they're handling it I
said to talk to you during my Q&A let's
stop for a selfie for these guys they're
making a real effort
[Music]
thank you guys take care that rappers
come home
a lot of people that you've been close
to that are friends and family workers
how have you got it now
a congressman I think there's a lot of
people that would like to do the same
but there's I think complexity to
working with it's about expectations of
day one homies you know I've been
successful with working you know xx it's
when you're talking about day when
homies I remember thinking about Joe and
moose and a couple of my college friends
who decided not to come to wine library
after college but they were invited
Brandon did come he was high school and
then obviously not cinema and like AJ
and all DJ's friends boo why my brain
I'm asleep when we go to the next
chapters there'll be a lot of people
right now that people know well it's
antique any or Markus and maybe whoever
might be so it I I really the thing that
when you talk to athletes or rappers or
you know anybody about day one homie is
it it plays into an interesting game
because it goes completely in the my
advice I'm about to give us a complete
contradiction to put more positive
people around you and cut out people who
don't bring value what is very cliche is
that when you have a star an earner the
engine the thing there's always people
around it that are day one that are so
incredibly instrumental in being
emotionally there and friends and and
maybe not even instrument a lot of times
they're just serendipity but now that
we're here think they believe the the
people around the the the earner the
Northstar think they made it
our guy or gal made it now we're here
but for that person the process has just
begun got it and what happens is a lot
of friction and you have the cliche
things that we've all seen in like TV
shows and have heard stories of like the
hangar honors it's like ludicrous but
then there's the one that we don't talk
about the one that's like you know like
the one that you see on TV shows and
movies is like cliche right like laying
around just enjoying the life you know
everybody watched Entourage like you
know I think the the the person that is
not talked about enough is actually your
homey who's really trying who just
doesn't have talent as the Machine gets
bigger as she that person gets bigger
[Music]
look what LeBrons luxury in that
scenario is the enormous talent and
capability of maverick he's a real guy
you know one of the most interesting
things for me in watching the business
culture over the last 20 years
[Music]
my planes massively delayed I've got to
do something else I made it go private
so give me I'm out of call but I just
want you guys to know what's going on
[ __ ] drop me in America yep yep
are you on Delta with me it's like yeah
I'm dead I gotta do I got work to do
around the draft this is real bad
okay okay keep updating me we're like
circling around the airport and I don't
want to hold them up too long so let's
uh let's get to some solutions ASAP okay
okay bye
let's go to the let's go to the Delta
terminal and then we'll just sit like
this if we can fly tissues gonna miss
the draft Chicago New York is always
challenging not good
we'll see teams working on it
can you all know they're forcing you
right now you know what give me let me
call you right back
give me trying to buy one minute try to
buy one minute yeah you can you can like
you can start rolling a little bit
because we can go past her and look yo
any updates cuz I'm like really
struggling to hang out here
and I'm in really bad shape here bro I
mean not only am I gonna be late I'm
gonna miss the whole draft we need to be
way more like yeah are we are we are we
calling do we call every private like
there we full okay so can we okay bye
let's let's let's do a circle let's do
one circle my 5:00 p.m. flight is now
leaving before the fours because the
fours are now sevens
god [ __ ] damnit I'm gonna miss the
draft
yep thank you so you're doing your thing
okay thank you I think I'm gonna go to
Delta right now that's unfortunately
where I think I'm at all right clean
issues are gonna make me miss half of
the [ __ ] draft so there's that but
all prospective baby as much as that
[ __ ] sucks and even though it's one
of my few days of enjoyment it's a lot
better than being dead